[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouveaux débats sur les
antennes de tv 78 radio sensations pour
les élections municipales du 15 et 22
mars prochains
durant la prochaine heure ce sont les
candidats déclarés à la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois qui vont exposer et
débattre de leurs programmes respectifs
ils sont quatre autour de cette table
pour rappel leur temps de parole seront
chronométrés durant toute cette émission
et nous avons effectué un tirage au sort
en vue de la première prise de parole le
hasard a voulu que ce soit vous philippe
guiguet qui commence y est tête de liste
des clés avec vous 2020 vous êtes le
premier adjoint finances depuis huit ans
de véronique côté millard si l'édile
actuelle vous a pas choisi comme son
favori vous est en revanche soutenu par
l'ensemble des représentants de la
droite locale
dites nous pourquoi les clés siens
doivent-ils voté pour vous le 15 mars
prochain
alors tout d'abord une petite précision
ça fait pas uniquement un mandat je suis
l'avion venant aux finances mais trois
mandats ça fait deux mandats
oui que je suis là je suis le premier
rang le premier adjoint et je ne suis
pas soutenu uniquement par la droite
locale mais je j'accompagne une liste
sans étiquette
même sans titre personnel même si moi
meme je sui divers divers droite voilà
est donc en soi les styles pourquoi les
clés les questions de devrait-il voté
pour moi la première raison à mon avis
c'est que j'ai toujours beaucoup envie
de servir notre ville la seconde comme
vous venez de le dire j'ai une
antériorité sur un certain nombre de
postes
et donc le maîtrise de dossiers la
troisième est que je suis rejoint par la
majorité des adjoints et conseillers
municipaux de l'équipe actuelle la
quatrième c'est que j'aurai le temps et
la disponibilité d'être pleinement au
service des clés sien pendant ce
prochain mandat que j'ai malgré tout
déjà réussi à faire malgré une activité
professionnelle très chargé depuis près
de 20
dans stéphanie jamin tête de lice des
têtes de listes d'énergie positive c'est
votre première expérience politique vous
êtes la seule et autour de cette table a
peut être élu au conseil municipal vous
habitez les clayes-sous-bois depuis une
trentaine d'années investit aussi dans
la vie locale pourquoi les clés siens
doivent-ils voter pour vous alors nous
avons choisi de présenter pour les
élections municipales de mars 2020 une
liste citoyenne et attentive attentive à
tous à tous les clés siens que ce soit
les jeunes les moins jeunes et également
les seniors est également attentive à
tous les enjeux le lien social la
convivialité
donc nous ce que nous voulons c'est
proposer un regard de nouveau un regard
nouveau avec une nouvelle équipe et un
renouvellement de l'équipe municipale à
titre d'exemple nous avons un colistier
qui nous a rejoint il ya quelques temps
qui a été très séduit par notre façon de
travailler puisqu'il a été approché par
plusieurs personnes présentes ici et il
a il a beaucoup aimé notre façon de
travailler notre vision de la ville et a
sauté nous rejoindre voilà nicolas une
tête de liste d'un autre projet pour les
clayes-sous-bois élue d'opposition
depuis 15 ans vous êtes encartés chez
génération le mouvement de benoît hamon
à titre personnel pour cette élection
vous avez reçu le soutien de la plupart
des partis de gauche pcf europe ecologie
les verts mais aussi le parti socialiste
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est la première
fois que vous briguez le poste de
premier magistrat de la ville alors
pourquoi les glissières doivent-ils voté
pour vous bien tout simplement parce que
je crois que le nom de la liste que je
porte est assez explicite
un autre projet pour les
clayes-sous-bois c'est ce que nous
souhaitons mettre en place à l'avenir et
donc dès le 23 mars prochain
nous avons commencé à rencontrer de
nombreux que les siens puisque nous
travaillons sur ce projet depuis un an
désormais et nous avons mis en avant six
grandes thématiques
issu du travail concerté avec les clés
siens qui repose sur le respect de
l'environnement et la nécessaire
transition écologique locale une
politique de solidarité active une
sécurité efficace avec un triptyque qui
est prévenir agir et sanctionner une
dynamique de convivialité notamment qui
passe évidemment par l'horreur la
redynamisation pardon de notre coeur de
ville une maîtrise de notre organisme et
de notre cadre de vie est évidemment une
démocratie locale participative est
totalement renouvelé puisque dans
l'ensemble des des lutins des élus les
candidats je suis je vais déjà trop vite
des candidats qui sont qui font partie
de notre liste il n'y a aujourd'hui que
trois conseillers municipaux sortants et
le reste de l'équipe est évidemment
issus du collectif citoyen qui m'a
désigné pour porter cette liste enfin
une claire vraiment tête de liste les
clayes-sous-bois c'est vous membre de la
majorité municipale depuis 2001 vous
êtes actuellement adjointe en charge de
l'éducation soutenu par la république en
marche personnellement et le parti
animalistes vous bénéficiez aussi de
l'appui du maire actuel véronique côté
millard
pourquoi voulez vous la remplacez
pourquoi les clés siens doivent-ils
voter pour vous alors si vous le
permettez avant de répondre à cette
question je me présente et j'ai 55 ans
j'ai deux enfants de grand garçon de
bientôt 18 et 21 ans et d'ailleurs pour
le petit clin d'oeil mais mon jeune fils
de 18 ans votera pour la première fois
aux élections municipales le 15 mars
je suis également sapeur pompier depuis
35 ans et est déporté secours
l'attention l'intérêt que je porte aux
autres fait partie de mon adn
je suis également comme vous l'avez dit
adjointe au maire depuis deux mandats
je porte et j'assume complètement toutes
ces années parce que vous peut être aux
côtés de véronique côté millard et oui
je me présente aujourd'hui en tant que
candidate avec une équipe constituée de
claix siens avec les siennes de tous les
quartiers
toutes les générations de sensibilités
différentes et
et ont tous la même envie la même
ambition c'est ne pas porter l'intérêt
général de notre ville et je suis
extrêmement fier de conduire une liste
aujourd'hui soutenu par véronique côté
millard en effet maire sortante et
conseillère régionale udi voilà pourquoi
je pense que j'ai déjà répondu
pour beaucoup à cette question et en
plus en plus j'en ai l'envi j'en ai
l'envi j'aime les gens j'aime ma vie
j'aime tous les quartiers voilà les
présentations sont faites merci à vous
quatre avant de passer aux différentes
thématiques de ce débat je vous propose
de regarder ce sujet de la rédaction de
tv 78 qui pose quelques éléments de
cadrage et majeur aux clayes-sous-bois
pour ces élections un sujet de manon
varaldo que deviendra l'ancienne halle
du marché communal une des questions
d'aménagement de la ville
après la réhabilitation des écoles place
à la problématique de sécurité aux
abords mais aussi dans la ville faut-il
poursuivre le déploiement de la
vidéoprotection les objectifs de
logements sociaux ne sont pas encore
totalement rempli dans la commune il est
de 24,6 % pour un objectif fixé par la
loi de 25% d'ici 2025 les 0,4 pour cent
représente une cinquantaine de logements
aux clayes-sous-bois des futurs
logements vont sortir de terre en 2021
autre enjeu un manque de stationnement
dans le centre ville mais aussi autour
de l'espace socioculturel philippe
noiret beaucoup sont devenus payants
même problématique aux alentours du
centre commercial one nacion qui possède
la plus grande parapharmacie outlet de
france où la circulation est dense
le centre devra faire face à la future
concurrence du centre commercial
openskies a plaisir à contrario les clés
siens espèrent des embauches avec
l'ouverture de ce centre open sky prévue
pour avril 2020 autre chantier le centre
de recherche et développement en date
hausse devrait se conclure à l'été 2020
leur mission l'innovation dans le
domaine de l'ordinateur quantique et de
la cybersécurité 100 emplois seront
créés enfin une crainte pour les
habitants la diminution du nombre de
praticiens et les départs en retraite
non remplacés la création d'une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire est
souhaitée pour pallier
pénurie de médecins voilà pour les
enjeux première thématique de ce débat
pas évoquer forcément directement dans
ce sujet l'environnement les
clayes-sous-bois près de 18000 habitants
elle dispose de plusieurs espaces verts
notamment dans sa partie sud elle était
aussi entouré de terrains agricoles au
nord et à l'est évidemment
l'environnement est un sujet systémique
mobilité développement économique
urbanisme
libre à vous de vous positionner sur ce
thème est de dire aux téléspectateurs et
aux clés sien ce qui vous importe le
plus pour l'environnement local et
stéphanie germain du fait des temps de
parole vous allez débuter vous vous
prévoyez dévoiler vos premières mesures
demain lundi 10 février nous sommes le 9
donc le suspense est total vous avez
tout de même indiqué vouloir soutenir un
développement vraiment durable qu est ce
qu un développement vraiment durable
alors déjà je tiens à rappeler que le
développement durable ne se résume pas
qu'à l'écologie néanmoins je pense que
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on va se
concentrer aujourd'hui mais je suis tout
à fait consciente du fait que le
développement durable regroupe plusieurs
thématiques
nous avons utilisé le terme de
développement réellement durable puisque
depuis quelques années il a quand même
des aberrations
qui se sont produites aux clayes avec un
certain nombre de suppressions des
espaces verts ou des espaces verts qui
sont en cours d'être d'être supprimés je
parle notamment du centre de loisirs des
bruyères qui est pour moi une thématique
très très très cher à mon coeur puisque
j'ai fait partie l'association qu'il a
défendu qu'il défend encore donc je
pense que c'est important de d'avoir une
vraie politique du développement durable
avec trois grands axes que nous nous
privilégions c'est à dire la
végétalisation des espaces publics ça
passe par les îlots de fraîcheur dans
les cours mais également des jardins
partagés récupérer l'espace public
également au niveau des bâtiments
publics il ya tout un travail à faire
sur les économies d'énergie faire un
audit énergétique tout simplement on
peut le faire avec des partenariats
décolle enfin il ya plein de choses à
faire et pour finir il ya les mobilités
douces qui sont effectivement à
privilégier on voit bien oakley qu il ya
des efforts qui ont été faits avec
certaines pistes cyclables mais qui sont
malheureusement pas entretenues et des
travaux qui ont été faits et très
récemment sur la musique ferry pour ne
citer qu'elles il n'ya pas déménagement
sur les petits clubs qui ont été qui ont
été faites donc c'est un peu dommage et
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire sur ces trois thématiques et nous
devons engager là dedans
philippe d'hygiène libre à vous de et
notamment de répondre puisque vous êtes
issu de la majorité sortante vous selon
vos propositions j'ai noté développer
des jardins partagés je suppose que vous
avez d'autres idées ambition pour notre
programme sera dévoilé dans une dans une
dizaine de jours sur les thématiques
évoquées par ma collègue est si présente
je ne peux qu'abonder le développement
durable ça n'est pas un mot c'est un
ensemble de thématiques c'est une
thématique sur la mobilité
c'est une thématique sur l'énergie c'est
une thématique sur la végétalisation
nous proposerons un certain nombre
d'exemples concrets lors de notre de
notre programme définitif les
clayes-sous-bois il ya le terme bois
nous savons très bien que au niveau de
la commune aujourd'hui nous avons
beaucoup d espace où nous pourrons
revégétaliser aussi bien des espaces qui
sont des délais c'est que comme des
espaces qui ont déjà été
imperméabilisées pour ce qui est de la
thématique de l'espace des bruyères
effectivement l'espace des bruyères
il ya une décision qui nous a été
proposé par madame le madame le maire ps
d'evry a juste précisé l'ancien centre
l'ancien l'ancien centre des bruyères
il ya une proposition qui a été faite
par madame le maire de ne pas continuer
sur cette sur cette position initiale
moi personnellement dans la mesure où
les services étaient toujours rendues
vis-à-vis des clés siens bien entendu je
ne me suis pas opposé néanmoins suite un
certain nombre de réactions
nous avons pu dans le cadre du projet
définitif qui va être proposé de la
résidence pour personnes âgées d'à
d'arriver à obtenir un espace vert de
près de 800 mètres carrés qui viendra
compenser une partie de l'espace
initiale elle nicolas eu sur sur
l'environnement le développement durable
local et aussi peut-être sur les
bruyères
quelles sont vos propositions libre à
vous aussi de vous interpeller et de
répondre je peu surpris de ce qui vient
d'être annoncé par monsieur guy guen sur
le fait qu'il ne semblait pas être
d'accord avec madame le maire alors que
tout le monde a voté toutes les
décisions toutes les délibérations qui
ont été prises pour la destruction du
centre de loisirs des bruyères sur
lequel moi je me pose depuis évidemment
2015 il y a eu d'ailleurs une très large
mobilisation de la population puisque
2500 personnes nous ont suivi ont
rejoint une pétition que nous avions
lancée pour précisément maintenir ce
centre de loisirs des brières ou en tout
cas cet espace vert en centre ville
je rappelle que le parc des bruyères
c'est quand même sept mille mètres
carrés
en plein coeur de ville c'est
aujourd'hui une position totalement
anachronique par rapport à ce que l'on
peut connaître par ailleurs et dans
d'autres communes que la partie de votre
projet sur développement tout à fait les
brouillards le centre de bio des
bruyères nounou le sauvegarde rond
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune aucune
possibilité pour que le fin de la
résidence seniors s'installe de manière
définitive
nous avons encore la possibilité de
revenir derrière et pour nous il est
essentiel que ce centre en tout cas cet
espace en plein centre ville en plein
coeur de ville soit maintenue sur le
développement durable il y a quatre
thèmes nous qui évidemment nous tiennent
à coeur et qu'il ne faut que l'on m en
met en avant par don sur sur les
clayes-sous-bois les circulations douces
l'ailé
l'économie circulaire pardon et bien
entendu aussi tout ce qui relève de
pardon le plan énergétique qui pour nous
sont essentiels à mettre en oeuvre au
sein de la ville on va laisser
s'exprimer un clerc frémont sur ce sujet
aussi vous pourrez reprendre la parole
est effectivement fait les billets n'ont
ensuite pour qu'on ait déjà fait un tour
de table
vous êtes quelque part visé puisque
soutenu par la maire sortante quels sont
vos projets aussi sur le développement
durable j'ai pu lire que vous souhaitiez
aussi développer les circulations douces
alors moi je préfère parler de respect
de l'environnement plutôt que
développement durable surtout à
l'échelle locale
il est vrai que le respect de
l'environnement touche moi je dirais
toutes les thématiques c'est la faire de
tous ces dunes la sphère de tous les
clés siens avec les siennes c'est
également la faire de nous des services
des services publics de nous améliorer
pleinement en effet le respect de
l'environnement pour ça nos possibilités
sont nombreuses parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya six ans - le dernier mandat
personne ne parlait respect
l'environnement a parlé les partis
écologistes
aujourd'hui tout le monde en parle donc
c'est vrai que je pense que ça va être
un gros enjeu des six années à venir et
tout le monde est prêt à faire des
efforts parce que en effet il est en
voie là pour parler des bruyères
je connais bien c'est ma délégation
j'assume pleinement le choix que nous
avons fait centre de loisirs fermer en
2015 je recadre le jamais déplacé
déplacer à elle aussi l'ancien site
permet en tout cas tout à fait et
j'assume clairement je vais pleinement
je vais essayer de vous expliquer très
rapidement pourquoi nous avions un
centre de loisirs les bruyères qui était
essentiellement occupée par les enfants
pendant les vacances avec une baisse
drastique de l'occupation puisqu'à la
fin on était à environ 50 enfants qui
fréquentaient le centre par jour à côté
de cela nous avions douze écoles dont 11
qu'il fallait réhabiliter mettre aux
normes personnes à mobilité réduite
donc 5 millions d'euros pour 50 enfants
ont cinq millions d'euros pour deux
mille enfants qui fréquentent les écoles
aujourd'hui avec en plus des écoles à
moitié vide
je pense que c'était de notre
responsabilité d'élus de changer
d'orientation
c'est la raison pour laquelle ces 5
millions avec ses 5 millions d'euros
nous avons commencé à réhabiliter les
écoles et à les mettre en accès pmr et
également fait un centre de loisirs dans
une école à moitié vide adaptée aux
rythmes de l'enfant
aujourd'hui philippe biganos étiez
réagir quand nicolas eut donné la parole
uniquement une réaction je n'avais pas
été contre la position de madame le
maire avaient approuvé cette position
dans la mesure il y avait un transfert
de services et dans la mesure où les
dispositions financières que je
permettais d'amener pour réhabiliter les
écoles étaient utilisés dans les deux
les écoles c'est à dire l'équivalent de
5 millions d'euros
en tout cas le centre de loisirs débris
est un sujet majeur stéphanie a jamais
on va on va se focaliser un peu sur ce
sujet directement ce qui est très
important moi j'aurai deux questions à
poser c'est la première ça va être la
question de l'engagement
ce qu'effectivement tout ce que vous
dites sur le développement durable le
respect de l'environnement je l'entends
je le comprends je le partage et aucun
sujet là dessus mais ça fait 18 ans que
vous n'avez rien fait en fait dans cette
logique là quand je prends l'exemple
devant l'église qui a été ou non
supprimer les arbres devant la salle
paroissiale où il y avait du gazon et en
allant on l'a fait pour faire un parking
qui est maintenant bétonner les peaux
l'epo dans la rue henri prou les arbres
sont en dépôt en fait faillite il ya
plein de choses qui me qui me pose
question donc moi j'ai envie
effectivement de vous de vous écouter de
vous faire confiance mais néanmoins
cette première chose et est-ce que vous
reviendriez vous sur le projet je crois
que le terrain a été vendu est ce que
c'est possible de revenir en arrière et
de faire un autre projet alors pour
l'instant effectivement il ya une
promesse de vente des trompes et moi si
j'ai foam effectivement une promesse de
vente qui a été signé qui doit être
libre de tout recours
actuellement il ya un recours qui est
qui qui est fait par l'association dont
je suis la trésorière est effectivement
notre objectif c'est de faire casser ce
permis de construire
nicolas lui vaut aussi c'est votre
position sur ce centre de loisirs des
sciences nos positions et elle n'a pas
varié depuis 2015
ce n'est pas uniquement le centre de
loisirs c'est justement cette
respiration nous avons en centre ville
de 7000 m² qui me paraît indispensable
de pouvoir préserver avec d'autres
projets à l'intérieur il ya peut-être
des sujets à revoir sur la question du
centre et du mode de garde des enfants à
l'intérieur de ce centre en matière de
centres de loisirs on peut imaginer un
lieu intergénérationnel qui permettent à
toutes les générations de pouvoir
rentrer dans notre dans ce centre et
dans cet espace dans cet espace dans cet
espace verdoyant et il me semble moi
aujourd'hui qu'il est nécessaire puisque
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une volonté
justement de transition est de passer à
une transition écologique et climatique
de garder cette cet espace
naturel en plein coeur de ville et
surtout de pouvoir visualiser tout ce
qui est à perméabilité aujourd'hui et ce
qui peut l'être notamment les cours
d'école pour partie d'entrée on va
continuer quelques secondes sur ce
centre de loisirs puisque visiblement
c'est un sujet très important pour vous
et et pourrait pour les chrétiens juste
une question d'ordre technique pensez à
vous reculez pour pas que la caméra
cache cache nicholas hughes voilà
parfait merci
c'est une leçon technique c je suis
désolé du coup philippe qui viennent
puisque vous avez un peu de retard sur
le temps de parole si vous souhaitiez
ajouter des éléments là dessus je vais
juste répondent à votre à votre remarque
je ne vous suis pas tout à fait dans
votre remarque parce que nous avons une
adjointe au développement durable depuis
déjà deux mandats nous avons mis en
place la semaine du développement
durable depuis déjà deux mandats nous
avons été en avance sur tout ce qui est
zéro phyto depuis trois ans au niveau de
l'eau de la commune
nous avons déjà prévu un certain nombre
d'études pour passer sur du
photovoltaïque sur un certain nombre de
bâtiments
nous avons commencé à croître le parc de
véhicules électriques
donc où je vous suis c'est que la
situation d'il ya 15 ans n'est pas du
tout la même qu'aujourd'hui mais notre
volonté nous l'avons déjà et il faudra
rester dans une volonté incitatif à
clairfayts montré très rapidement et
ensuite on change de sujet parce qu'on
arrive presque à la mère elle a la
moitié de cette émission il ya d'autres
thématiques abordées sur ce sujet mais
très rapidement sur l'un des faits pour
terminer déjà plus mon verre de la ville
moi je pense que c'est comme ce terrain
là n'est pas le poumon vert de la ville
nous avons une forêt nous avons
un parc de vialle nous avons un parc à
rio qui sont je pense que mon verre de
la ville après qu'est ce que nous avons
fait à la place de ce projet là
devrait être construite une foyer
logement pour les personnes âgées qui
sont récents du logement visiblement oui
qui est très attendu par les personnes
âgées qui sont encore indépendantes qui
vont être en plein centre ville avec
possibilité d'aller partout à pied est
également nous avons tout de même garder
un parc arboré qui va permettre j'espère
de faire tout un tas de projets
intergénérationnels
j'aime stéphanie jamin excusez moi très
rapidement mais vraiment très rapidement
mais effectivement on parlera du
problème de l'engagement de la confiance
puisque effectivement ça faisait partie
des promesses de campagne de 2014 cette
rénovation centre de loisirs des
bruyères mais je pense que ça pourrait
être évoquée après sur la démocratie
néanmoins je voudrais juste posé la
question de cette résidence seniors qui
restent finalement une résidence
services on sait tous on pourra
peut-être vous pourrez peut être vous
répondre via internet réseaux sociaux et
puis les clés siens pourront se rendre
dans vos réunions publiques pour pouvoir
peut-être plus d'éléments sur sur ce
sujet puisqu'on parlait des seniors une
thématique qui les concerne au premier
plan c c'est la santé dans ce débat qui
est diffusée sur tv 78 radio sensations
sujet de préoccupation est effectivement
du fait du vieillissement de la
population mais des praticiens aussi de
l'évolution du métier des pratiques la
ville des clés soit perdu près de 40% de
ces généralistes en dix ans selon des
données de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé d'île de france
ils sont huit aujourd'hui sur la commune
d'île de france sur la commune des
clayes-sous-bois et 88 % de ses médecins
ont plus de 55 ans voilà des éléments de
cadrage que faire alors pour attirer les
plus jeunes médecins et répondre aux
besoins de la population qui a vieilli
stéphanie jamin vous avez la parole sur
le sujet alors effectivement
je rejoins les trois personnes qui sont
autour de cette table sur la partie
maison médicale néanmoins je pense que
ce n'est pas la solution à tous
puisqu'il faut attirer dans un premier
temps les praticiens et non pas et n'ont
pas décidé au niveau de la mairie qu'il
faut une maison médicale ce que comme on
le voit à plaisir ce qui se passe c'est
à dire que vous avez une maison
individuelle
il manque de médecins il en recherche
donc je pense qu'il faut surtout
travailler avec les associations que les
associations de médecins travailler avec
la communauté de communes de saint
quentin qui propose beaucoup de choses
et concertée les médecins
à ce sujet néanmoins je sais que c'est
effectivement un gros problème parce que
vous n'avez qu'un généraliste et un seul
qui n'ait pour une population de 17
points de vue des 1000 habitants nicolas
hulot vous êtes aussi vous favorable à
la création d'une maison de santé tout à
fait oui nous lui portons dans le projet
que nous avons présenté donc il ya
quelques quelques jours maintenant la
création d'une maison de santé est
évidemment nécessaire sur la commune je
note d'ailleurs que il ya eu un réel
manque d'anticipation de la part de la
majorité sortante
puisque ce problème est connu comme vous
le rappeliez tout à l'heure depuis
quelques années maintenant qu'il ya eu
un plan départemental qui a été proposé
en 2017 avec le financement de maisons
de santé nous n'avons pas en tout cas la
majorité sortante n'a pas souhaité
sinclair dans ce dans ce projet il y a
eu un déblocage de fonds de la part de
l'assurance maladie de plus de 35
millions d'euros pour pouvoir financer
ces maisons de santé et pour voir
financer le fonctionnement de ces
maisons de santé
l'avim évidemment n'ayant pas de maison
de santé n'a pas pu y prétendre
aujourd'hui il est nécessaire et
évidemment de pouvoir résorber cette ce
départ est cette carence que nous
connaissons sur la ville en terme de
santé en créer une maison de santé qui
peut être évidemment une maison de santé
en lien avec l'ensemble des praticiens
que nous connaissons sur la commune et
qui peuvent justement travaillé à
garnier entre guillemets cette maison
semble un petit peu juste pour la suite
de l'émission c'est un sujet important
soutien majeur effectivement france en
général et donc il faut être vraiment
assez proactif sur 7 sur ce sujet là ce
qui n'a pas été la majorité sortante et
donc il y a des possibilités pour
pouvoir travailler sur cette maison de
santé avec la fac de médecine de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis bien entendu les mutuelles qui
interviennent sur ce sujet là mais
pourquoi pas donc travailler sur aussi
un centre de soins mutualistes
en clair frémont vous proposez aussi une
maison de santé
et puis mutuelle municipal pour les plus
fragiles sont certaines de vos
propositions exactement nous proposons
une maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
parce que vous
et que nous allions bientôt manquer de
médecins certes dans quelques années
mais nous manquons également
foncièrement de paramédicaux aujourd'hui
donc il est important de voir à échelle
lille qui peut le mieux voir à échelle
line et c'est ce que nous proposons
c'est créer un conseil de santé avec les
médicaux et paramédicaux sur la ville
puisque eux mieux que n'importe qui
peuvent nous dirons nous dire les
besoins de notre ville et nous dire
comment y arriver donc travailler avec
eux en effet sur un cahier des charges
qui nous permettent de proposer une
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé
attractive aux anneaux futurs médecins
et paramédicaux et à côté de ça en effet
nous avons une université à saint
quentin avec laquelle bien évidemment il
va falloir travailler
philippe bielle sur ce sujet je vais
être synthétique
parce que dès le mois de juin dit en
parlant dès le mois de juin nous avons
proposé une maison pur
pluridisciplinaire de santé qui est dit
pluridisciplinaire dit effectivement
médecins aussi bien généralistes que
spécialiste mais aussi paramédicaux au
niveau des médecins
je n'exclus pas même d'embaucher des
médecins au niveau de la municipalité
j'ai été en contact avec un adjoint au
maire d'une ville proche qui a
municipaliser un certain nombre de
médecins et on sait très bien qu'au
niveau du coût financier
ça peut être neutre au niveau de l'
embauche de ses médecins il sera
nécessaire de travailler avec des
partenaires comme saint quentin en
yvelines comme la rs c'est à dire l'
agence régionale de santé comme
effectivement l'université je suis
déléguée à l'univ aux universités et
nous avons en prévision un hôpital du
futur au niveau de saint quentin donc
nous aurons les possibilités de travail
de travailler avec 7,7 hôpital de
futures et j'ai déjà pris acte avec un
certain nombre de professionnels de
santé de la commune aussi bien des
médecins que des paramédicaux que
pharmacien pour créer justement un
comité local de professionnels de santé
de la commune
c'était fini jamais ce que vous
souhaitiez encore rebondir sur cette
thématique de la santé vous avez
un peu de temps où on peut passer une
autre thématique effectivement je suis
assez interpellés parce que je partage
enfin effectivement on arrive tout c'est
là la conclusion qui est un problème de
pénurie de médecins de médecins c'est un
fait
néanmoins j'ai l'impression que rien n'a
été fait ces dernières années en fait
par rapport à ça et j'aimerais juste
avoir une explication si c'est possible
qu'est ce qui fait que maintenant on va
pouvoir changer les choses alors qu'à
voir ce n'est pas possible
publiez vous semblez être je
l'interpellé je vais faire enfin où ma
collègue nous faut trouver de la même
parce que c'était selon l'ars en vogue à
tous tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui il va y avoir les moyens
pour essayer d'avoir des partenaires
pour répondre à cette question au niveau
des locaux je sais que au niveau de la
commune nous avons acquis un bâtiment
qui est la sécurité sociale avec trois
plateaux de 2 300 m² 900 m² donc nous
avons les moyens
effectivement au niveau matériel de le
faire mais ça ne suffit pas il faut
effectivement comme vous l'avez décrit
tout à l'heure aller chercher tous ces
médecins ainsi que les paramédicaux on
va on va poursuivre ce débat du premier
tour des élections municipales pour la
ville des clayes-sous-bois avec la
thématique de la sécurité un sujet que
la plupart d'entre vous mentionne dans
leurs programmes respectifs avec tout de
même en filigrane à un problème de
recrutement on le sait sur le territoire
d'agents municipaux
anne-claire frémont vous êtes vous
favorable au déploiement de la
vidéosurveillance pour la sécurité aussi
la mutualisation pour parvenir à une
police intercommunale
alors je suis favorable à continuer à
déployer la vidéoprotection sur la ville
il est vrai que la sécurité en effet
c'est un gros domaines c'est normalement
un point qui dépend qui est de
compétence de l'état
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que l'état
n'est plus en mesure d'assurer une
police nationale constance sur notre
ville donc je pense que c'est de notre
responsabilité en effet d'assurer la
sécurité et la tranquillité des
habitants
avec deux axes en effet déployé et se
donner les moyens de déployer une police
municipale de proximité et à côté de ça
travailler avec les villes voisines de
façon à créer mutualiser une police
intercommunale
nicolas hulot vous souhaitez vous je
vous cite un une sécurité pour une
sécurité efficace et effective crée
notamment une police de sécurité du
quotidien est ce que c'est différent de
la police municipale tout à fait puisque
comme le rappelle madame frémont pour
moi la sécurité en tout cas la démission
de des forces de police c'est un sujet
régalien la police de sécurité du
quotidien c'est une police de sécurité
qui est menée et dans les missions sont
portés justement par la police nationale
nous savons
c'est un peu surprenant que
vous intervenez sur le fait qu' il y
aujourd'hui une pénurie semble-t-il de
policiers sur la sueur sur le territoire
national puisque le ministre de
l'intérieur a indiqué ils y a un an
maintenant que à la fin du quinquennat
il y aurait dix mille agents de forces
de polices policiers nationaux ou
gendarmes supplémentaires
donc il faut impérativement que notre
commune se mobilisent et se mobilisent
avec les trois communes alentour ont
villepreux et plaisir parce que pour moi
il n'y a pas simplement à créer une
police ou intercommunal avec ou
mutualisé ou intercommunal avec plaisir
mais nous sommes évidemment un risque
d'effets avec vitreux donc il est
important que nous ayons une même axe de
réflexion sur ce sujet là et que nous
nous mobilisions tous pour mettre en
place une police de sécurité du
quotidien qui interviennent sur notre
commune est sûre du quartier qui
nécessitent notre présence stéphanie
jamin sur cette question de la sécurité
alors je vous précise vous avez un peu
de retard sur le temps de parole donc
l'eau libre avons déployé vous
arriveriez donc effectivement moi la
première chose que je veux rappeler
c'est que la municipalité a un rôle dans
la prévention au niveau de la sécurité
contrairement à la police nationale qui
est dans la répression
donc la vidéosurveillance on a une
centaine de caméras aux clayes-sous-bois
je pense pas que finalement ce soit
suffisant moi je crois beaucoup
effectivement à la police municipale
donner des moyens à cette police
municipale lui redonner des phares
redéfinir ses missions également tendre
vers quoi par exemple avoir déjà plus
effectif d'avoir des personnes qui sont
qui ont la possibilité de faire plus de
rondes d'avoir une vraie proximité avec
la population
avoir des gens qui peuvent se déplacer
notamment avec des vélo ou à pied
puisque finalement les clés siens sont
en demande de personnes enfin deux
policiers municipaux qu'ils puissent
facilement identifiés et auquel ils
peuvent se poser des questions et se
référer autre chose sur le domaine de la
sécurité il ya le conseil de
de prévention de la délinquance qui je
pense est à réactiver et à vraiment il
faut vraiment travailler avec la mairie
a son rôle à jouer dedans et on peut
mettre en place beaucoup de choses c'est
un gros sujet voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur la sécurité après il ya aussi
il faut pas oublier non plus la sécu
dont on parle de la sécurité de tout ce
qui peut se passer mais il ya aussi des
victimes et nous on a envie de proposer
aux victimes un accompagnement
quand elles sont victimes de
cambriolages ou d'agressions de leur
donner des informations aux nouvelles
associations il dit gagne sur cette
thématique de la sécurité
effectivement sans oublier la prévention
mais là nous sommes en train de parler
de la de la sécurité un certain nombre
de propositions concrètes relancer le
clspd que madame le maire n'a pas n'a
pas relancé le clspd c'est à dire le
comité local de sécurité de la
prévention de la délinquance
c'est le rapport à vous voilà c'est
voilà les développe des jeux
nous sommes d'accord il faut continuer à
croître la vidéosurveillance nous avons
95 caméra essentiellement focalisés sur
les liens par exemple précisé selon moi
compte tenu des coûts qui sont modérés
et maintenant pour la vidéosurveillance
on peut très bien augmenter de 30 ou 40
% le nombre le nombre de caméras il faut
modifier tout en restant avec des
effectifs budgétairement compatibles les
horaires de la police municipale nous
avons aujourd'hui six policiers
municipaux
nous en avons budgété 7 et enfin il faut
essayer aussi de d'attirer la conscience
des habitants en appartenant à des
associations type voisins vigilants de
manière à ce que tout le monde avait
conscience de la notion de sécurité au
quotidien
alors nicolas vous souhaitiez réagir
vous êtes en avance sur le temps de
parole donc la suite du débat c'est
important parce que
avait lancé sur la question de la
sécurité mais la question de la sécurité
c'est un triptyque que je déployer tout
à l'heure prévenir agir sanctionné et la
question de la prévention est évidemment
très importante est au coeur de notre de
notre projet avec la mise en place de
médiateurs sociaux et de correspondants
nuit puisque nous savons que c'est aussi
ennuyant soirée que beaucoup
d'incivilités peuvent se produire et
qu'il est important qu'il y ait un lien
entre les habitants et la police via la
médiation sociale sur la
vidéosurveillance une dernière chose
elle a atteint ses limites une étude
scientifique démontre que seuls 1 à 3%
des incivilités sont réglés via la vidéo
surveillance je pense que la présence
humaine ne remplacera jamais c'est juste
parce que vous avez par exemple deux
minutes dix amants sur un café mons qui
souhaite peut-être ajouter quelque chose
sur la sécurité
je vous ai dit en effet tout à l'heure
que nous étions tous acteurs de
l'environnement je pense que nous sommes
également tous acteurs de la de la
sécurité entre autres en effet avec ce
dispositif qui voisins vigilants où nous
pouvons tous être acteurs de la sécurité
et même bien plus et la prévention aussi
à son rôle bien évidemment en tant que
sapeur-pompier j'étais amené à faire à
mettre des actions en place dans le sens
de la prévention très tôt au sein des
écoles et on se rend compte que c'est
très efficace et moi je crois
foncièrement à ces actions de prévention
de la police des pompiers des acteurs de
la sécurité à face à face qu'il soit
connu de tous on va passer à la
thématique de la démocratie locale
notamment c'est un sujet qui est évoqué
aussi la par l'ensemble des candidats
aux clayes-sous-bois et dans l'ensemble
des communes
il y aura un nouveau maire au clae
souvent alors comment comment faire
vivre cette démocratie locale
comment rapprocher aussi les citoyens
des élus même si le maire est appréciée
généralement ddd citoyen on voit bien
qu'il y a qu il ya un gouffre qui est en
train de se créer entre élus et citoyens
philipp degen vos propositions sur la
démocratie locale
nos propositions déjà été énoncée en
partie dès le mois de juin 2019
premièrement nous mettrons en place un
conseiller municipal délégué justement
au comité de quartier de manière à être
sûr la proximité des clés sien ce qui
n'a pas eu lieu durant durant ce mandat
nous aurons des comités de quartier par
quartier
parce que les problématiques des
quartiers ne sont ne sont pas ne sont
pas les mêmes nous
d'autres ont chacun des quartiers d'un
budget d'investissement de manière à les
responsabiliser
parce que les clés sienne et que les
siens sont d'autant plus acteurs qui
sont responsabilisés nous souhaitons
donner aussi maintenant un temps de
parole après le conseil municipal hawk
les siennes etc les siens ce qui n'avait
pas pu être fait actuellement et il faut
surtout ce qui est les projets
structurants delà de la commune faire
une avancée régulière vis-à-vis de la
main de la population et enfin si
malheureusement un jour compte tenu des
difficultés financières il y avait
nécessité d'accroître la pression
fiscale la personnellement je m'engage à
ce que ce soit fait par voie
consultative auprès de la population
en clair vraiment sur cette question de
la démocratie locale
moi je dirais que fait partie de la
démocratie locale le mieux vivre
ensemble et c'est vrai que
c'est ce que souhaitent les clés siens
parce que et je pense d'ailleurs c'est
un petit peu nationale les élus sont
aujourd'hui trop éloignés trop éloigné
de tous et il faut se raccrocher
alors les moyens les moyens de se
rapprocher c'est tout bête c'est une
application une application que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui qui va permettre
aux clés sienne et que les siens 2
de dialoguer directement avec les
services de la ville et les élus
mais c'est aussi je pense beaucoup plus
de communication parce que lorsqu'on met
des projets en place il faut les faire
connaître les expliquer et pour ça il
faut communiquer est également moi je
suis feront je crois foncièrement en
effet à la mise en place d'un conseil de
ville
un conseil de ville intergénérationnel
où tout jeune l'enfant pourra participer
avec un budget participatif donc avec va
avec un pouvoir
je pense que c'est ça la démocratie
stéphanie jamin c'est l'un des points
sur lesquels vous insistez le plus dans
ce début de campagne
quelles sont vos propositions sur cette
thématique alors sur la démocratie
participative nous notre objectif
finalement c'est de redonner confiance
aux clés siens qu'il voie de la
transparence dans la gestion de notre
ville puisque effectivement les gens ont
besoin d'avoir de l'information de
connaître ce qui se passe dans leur
ville ce qui ce qui leur manquait comme
ces dernières années donc en fait on a
envie de leur
de leur proposer deux choses c'est à
dire de pouvoir assister aux conseils
municipaux et d'avoir un temps des
changes en début de conseil municipal
pour ne pas les bloquer pendant des
heures à assister au débat également
leur donner l'ordre du jour en amont
pour qu'ils puissent s'intéresser à ce
que ça c'est important parce que aller
au conseil municipal comme vous ne savez
pas ce qui se passe c'est compliqué nous
souhaitons également tenir nos
engagements
quand on s'engage à faire quelque chose
on veut travailler dessus
on veut également les associés non il ya
nicolas mahut s'est retourné sur parole
et la vie que les pas pris la parole
encore et pourtant vous êtes vous êtes
devant donc allez-y négligemment
également les associés les associés de
manière régulière sur des projets
importants comme les ventes de biens
immobiliers ou sur des sujets
particuliers comme les horaires
d'accueil les menus de la cantine qu'on
veut vraiment les remettre au coeur du
débat
et la deuxième chose quand on parle de
démocratie participative dans notre
liste on a envie de travailler avec
l'opposition s'étant c'est quelque chose
qui nous qui nous tient tient à coeur et
on veut travail avec l'opposition
et ça passe par plusieurs choses
notamment le fait de donner la
présidence d'une commission rogatoire à
l'opposition ce sera la commission
d'appel d'offres preuve qu'on avait
envie vraiment de concerter travailler
ensemble nicolas eu vous aurez du coup
peu la parole sur le sujet pour qu'on
puisse respecter les temps de parole un
maximum je comprends mais pourtant c'est
un peu un sujet important
ces gens c'est non mais moi je suis
assez surpris et en même temps ravi que
tout d'un coup les deux membres de la
majorité sortante soit converti à la
démocratie locale puis la démocratie
participative notamment puisque c'est
des sujets qui n'ont pas forcément été
suivies d'effet ces dernières ces
dernières années et depuis 19 ans
maintenant je prenais juste un exemple
tout à l'heure qui était justement le
la volonté de concertation des clés
siens sur des projets structurants comme
le centre de loisirs des bruyères et la
halle du marché qui avait réuni plus de
2500 personnes pour pouvoir entamer une
concertation avec les élus
ça n'a pas été possible je suis surpris
et ravi de voir que cela change dans
l'esprit de des élus sortants et pour
moi il est important évidemment que les
clés siens reprennent la parole en la
concertation ne soit admise au sein de
la commune avec notamment des votations
citoyennes sur des grands projets
structurants
merci on va il reste un quart d'heure
démission avant de passer à la
conclusion va pouvoir aborder mais du
coup très très rapidement cette
thématique même qui est importante qui
est quel urbanisme j'avais espéré en
tout cas préparé pour qu'on puisse
parler du centre des loisirs des
bruyères chose déjà faite
du coup je voulais vous poser à chacun
une simple question est-ce que moratoire
ou pas sur la construction des logements
est très rapidement avoir votre avis sur
sur sur la construction de nouveaux
logements ou pas aux clayes-sous-bois
avec la frémont sur cette question-là
précise pour qu'on puisse se passer à la
conclusion s'il vous plaît mais moi je
vais je vais vous donner de chiffres
précis
en 1982 il y avait dix sept mille
habitants aux clayes-sous-bois en 2017
on en a dix sept mille six cents ça
répond au fait que par les bétons
construction aujourd'hui c'est jouer
avec la peur on a la grande chance aux
clayes-sous-bois d'être entre deux
villes est entouré d'un bois donc on ne
pourra pas explosé on ne pourra pas
s'étendre
la question se pose pas pour vous donc
la question ne se pose pas il ya juste
un point c'est qu'il faut très
rapidement que nous arrivions au 25 % de
logements sociaux que l'on nous demande
et nous souhaitons qu'il en montre de
il en manque très peu nous en avons 24,6
si c'était oui des lieux aussi dans le
sud donc il nous en manque très peu et
c'est notre première objectifs et du
logement social dans tous les quartiers
c'est dans tous les projets stéphanie
jamin sur sur la construction de
nouveaux logements ou pas alors je
rejoins effectivement madame vraiment
il il faut bien effectivement accueillir
cette nouvelle population et ses
nouveaux blessés on est pas du tout
contre le fait de construire de nouveaux
logements
néanmoins nous ce qu'on veut c'est
reprendre la maîtrise de notre
aménagement en ayant vraiment défini une
vraie stratégie et travailler avec les
promoteurs et non pas l'un vers ce si on
doit être très synthétique c'est
reprendre les clés notre aménagement
tout simplement
nicolas hulot lors du coup très très
rapidement puisque sinon la conclusion
sera très courte et sans terre désolée
c'est une affaire d invention c'est les
règles au gel en est soumise
je sais bien mais justement vous parliez
de moratoire c'est nous qui l'avons
proposé il m'apparaît aujourd'hui
important de proposer un moratoire pour
les nouvelles constructions à venir
parce que nous avons bétonné beaucoup la
commune
comme le rappelle madame prénom ça ne
suit pas les objectifs puisque les
objectifs du p lus de 2004 était de
rajeunir la ville et lorsque l'on voit
malgré tout est malheureusement que
malgré toutes ces constructions ne vaut
pas à augmenter leur population c'est
mon arme c'est que pour le coup il y as
besoin d'un moratoire est de savoir
réellement cclat peut être le projet de
ville que nous souhaitons et nous un
projet de vie que nous souhaitons pour
notre commune en matière d'urbanisme
notamment philippe guillem sur cette
question treize logements très
simplement ce qui nous étions dix sept
mille en 2000 lorsque nous sommes
arrivés nous sommes au dernier
recensement 17 1725
mon objectif personnel et de la liste
que je que je conduis et de ne pas
dépasser les 18000 euros tout en
maîtrisant une rénovation urbaine avec
notre esprit village au niveau de la
commune au niveau des logements sociaux
25%
pas plus mais le 25 % avec de la qualité
pour l'ensemble des logements sociaux
voilà on arrive au terme de ce débat on
va passer à la conclusion peut-être voir
vos voilà vos temps de paroles qui
s'affichent vous êtes à peu près tous à
8 minutes sauf nicolas hulot qu'il y
aura du coup beaucoup moins de temps
pour conclure donc un temps de 1 temps
de conclusions pour voilà vous exprimer
sur un sujet qui vous est cher peut-être
revenir sur un point vous adresser aux
électeurs on prend l'ordre inverse de
l'introduction donc anne claire frémont
vous avez une minute trente pour pour le
faire jusqu'à deux minutes pour cette
conclusion alors moi je dirais que
l'humain
le vivre ensemble sont vraiment le fils
drôle de nos engagements pour notre
ville nous voulons un projet qui soit le
reflet de tout les clés siens tous les
quartiers et les attentes de tous les
questions depuis plusieurs mois nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des clés
siens nous leur avons soumis nos idées
mais surtout nous avons écouté les leurs
et après plusieurs mois de travail je
pense que nous pouvons aujourd'hui
proposer un programme qui réponde aux
attentes de tous en parallèle je porte
et j'assume pleinement le bel héritage
des trois mandats de madame véronique
côté millard maire sortante
néanmoins je ne suis pas véronique côté
millard et je suis anne k frémont avec
une nouvelle équipe constituée de dix 10
membres de la majorité actuelle est
renouvelée aux deux tiers avec de
nouveaux projets un programme et des
engagements pour les six années à venir
nicolas us et avoue 30 secondes maximum
malheureusement si vous les 15 et 22
mars prochains les questions auront un
choix déterminant à effectuer pour notre
commune les 15 et 22 mars prochain je
souhaite et je leur propose de donner un
nouvel élan à notre ville les 15 et 22
mars prochain je les invite à porter
leur choix sur une liste qui prône la
transparence la vérité l'ambition
collective et le respect les 15 et 22
mars prochains
un autre projet est possible le 23 mars
prochain nous mettrons en place ensemble
merci stéphane jamain une minute trente
pour conclure il blanche effectivement
minutes 30 mai
moi effectivement j'ai envie de
m'adresser aux électeurs et de leur dire
qu'effectivement le 15
le 15 mars prochain nous leur proposons
une équipe renouvelée à nos
renouvellement finalement de l'équipe
municipale avec un regard neuf qui est
très en phase avec les priorités du 21e
siècle
qu'est-ce que sont le développement
réellement durable et la gestion
transparente le 15 mars
on nous lors le 15 mars ne leur
proposant une équipe compétente à leur
écoute
à l'écouté de tous avec un cadre
convivial une ville vivante garante du
lien social
donc le 15 mars je vous invite à inviter
énergie positive liste citoyenne et
attentive et philippe guillen même chose
une minute trente pour conclure alors
nos objectifs ce sera le mieux vivre
ensemble
l'inter génial générationnel en plus
nous considérons que le prochain maire
devra être un maire bon gestionnaire
compte tenu des difficultés des communes
actuellement le prochain maire devra
être un maire à 100% disponible ce que
je m'engage à faire le prochain maire
devra être à l'écouté de tous ses
administrés et de toutes les équipes ce
que je m'engage à faire le prochain
maire devra être entouré d'une équipe
qui aura une expérience et une
compétence suffisante
ce qui est le cas avec l'équipe les
claies avec vous 2020 qui m'a rejoint
et le prochain maire des
clayes-sous-bois ne devra pas être isolé
car compte tenu de la situation
financière des communes
il faudra travailler en partenariat et
je suis très satisfait d'avoir le
soutien de la communauté d'agglomération
du département et de la région ce qui
aujourd'hui pour moi est beaucoup plus
important que d'avoir le soutien de
l'état quand l'on voit que l'état a
diminué notre dgf de plus de 40% depuis
les trois dernières années
voilà pourquoi la liste que je conduis
et je pense la liste adapté pour la
prochaine municipalité merci à vous
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat du
premier tour pour les élections
municipales aux clayes-sous-bois on va
prêter de voir autant de paroles
s'afficher un peu d' avance du coup pour
nicolas hulot on va essayer de rétablir
effectivement cessé temps de parole
d'ici le premier tour des élections je
le rappelle le 15 mars pour choisir
notre
un nouveau maire oak les sous-bois cette
émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et nos applications mobiles
aussi à réécouter sur radio sensations à
bientôt les municipales se poursuivre
évidemment sur les antennes de tv sur
l'antenne de tv 78 merci beaucoup
[Musique]
le